You have to learn on your own
because you're motivated to learn.
Hi there, Steve Kaufmann here, and today I
want to talk about artificial intelligence
and it's application to language learning.
Remember, if you enjoy these
videos, please subscribe.
Click on the bell for notifications
and uh, please follow me on a podcast
service, especially if you're working
on your English, you can carry the
audio with you and, and, um, I find that
very effective in language learning.
So, artificial intelligence.
Um, you know, I use artificial,
first of all, I should say that, uh,
October the eighth was my birthday.
Uh, my son and his family were over and
I got this new golf shirt, so I'm happy.
77th birthday.
Anyway, artificial intelligence, so
I use artificial intelligence, uh, in
the way I learn languages already, and
I think we're just at the beginning of
what artificial intelligence can do.
I use it, for example, when I, uh, watch
a television program on MTV Lebanon,
uh, or some other website in Persian
and then I download the MP3 file and
then I put it on Happy Scribe, which
is an automatic transcription service.
So that is artificial
intelligence as I understand it.
I see artificial intelligence as using,
uh, basically computing power to do
things much more quickly and much more
efficiently than humans could do it.
And thereby giving humans the benefit
of this tremendous ability to select and
to, uh, parse and to divide and, and all
the different things that, uh, that, uh,
the computer can do to audio and to text.
Uh, and thereby make it easier for a
learner to learn from that, uh, material.
So I put, I get these MP3 files, I
get this trans, you know, transcribed.
And then I'm able, and maybe it's a
type of, uh, artificial intelligence,
I'm able to import the audio and
the text very easily into LingQ.
So then I have the ability to
study this material on LingQ.
So that's a basic use of
artificial intelligence.
I think every time I go to Google
Translate to translate something,
the machine is translating it for me.
So in both cases, the computer is going at
this large corpus of, uh, you know, audio
or text material that it's been through,
and is able to draw certain conclusions
very, very quickly, much more quickly than
a human could possibly dream of doing.
So you get an instant translation,
which may or not, may not be as
accurate as what a human could do,
but that accuracy is improving.
So, but, but where do I see auto, or at
least the artificial intelligence going?
So I did some Googling, uh, of, you
know, how people are using artificial
intelligence for language learning.
And of course a lot of it relates
to the sort of teacher perspective.
So we will use artificial intelligence
to provide feedback to the learner
because the teacher thinks that a
major role for the teacher is to
provide feedback to the learner.
Personally, I'm not that
interested in feedback.
Or artificial intelligence can be used
to evaluate the learner, grade the
learner, maybe grade the learner in a
way that's more private than or less
damaging to the learner's self-esteem.
Uh, or less time consuming for the
teacher, but still evaluating the learner.
I'm also not very interested in
being evaluated, so neither of those
two things really turn my crank.
Then they talk about, you know, coming up
with textbooks that are sort of catered to
the learner's weaknesses or difficulties.
Now we're getting a little closer, but
that's not how, how I would use it.
What I see artificial intelligence and,
and what I think we're gonna try to
introduce more and more at LingQ is be
because language earning is, is very
much an individual thing, a personal
thing you can't, you can't expect people
to constantly correct you and guide you
and give you feedback and evaluate you.
And that somehow that
way you're gonna learn.
You have to learn on your own
because you're motivated to learn
and therefore you wanna find
content that's at your level.
That's of interest to you.
You know all the different ways
in which you can define content
that's gonna help you learn.
If you identify a voice or type of
voice that you like, maybe you can find
more material with that kind of voice.
For example, you can find more material
uh, of a certain regional accent,
perhaps maybe I could, uh, I should be
able to dictate to the using, you know,
voice commands, which is artificial
intelligence and say find me something
that's 20 minutes long on the, uh, recent,
uh, you know, demonstrations in Iran.
Maybe some discussion.
Maybe I could even say that I want the
percentage of new words to be X, sort of
thing, might be more difficult because
there will be some competing definitions.
Maybe if you want it too simple,
it can't deal with more complicated
topics, but these are things
that would have to be worked out.
Or I want a book, I want a book, an
audio book and a and um, electronic
book but I don't want it too long.
And again, I want it on a
certain subject, maybe Iranian
history or something like that.
Maybe such a thing doesn't exist, but
the amount of time that I spend looking
for material, if that could be automated,
so someone could automatically find
that for me, that would be amazing.
Now we also have text to speech,
which is a form of artificial
intelligence, but most text to speech
is still not so pleasant to listen to.
The voice sounds a bit artificial,
but it's getting better all the time.
Is it possible that we would get to
where, you know, you'd find a text
somewhere, something written in Wikipedia
or whatever it might be, or a book
that doesn't have an audio version.
It's not an audio book, but the quality
of text to speech would be so good that
would actually be pleasant to listen to.
A possible use of, um, artificial
intelligence once you have material, say
that you've imported into LingQ, another
problem I have with a, with a current
state of artificial intelligence is time
stamping because when I study content at
LingQ, I like to study in sentence mode.
So I have a sense, and I would like to
hear the audio just for that sentence.
But the timestamping is not accurate.
You know, I use, uh, Happy Scribe.
It says here you can timestamp.
And even within LingQ, we have an ability
to, you know, re-timestamp certain texts.
Apparently it's better in other
languages, but in Arabic and
versions it doesn't work very well.
So very accurately timestamped material,
matching the sentences that I'm studying
in LingQ, that raises another issue if I
get something automatically transcribed...
now again, the accuracy of that
transcription is improving all the time.
So if I have audio material, I
would like to read it, I go to
Happy Scribe, it's 90% accurate.
That's a problem when you're
learning the language.
Another problem is there's no punctuation.
So therefore, some of the sentences
that I would like to study in
sentence mode are in fact a paragraph
because there was no punctuation.
So as all of this improves, I could
maybe say, I want the sentences to
be between eight and 12 words long.
And so then, The text and the
corresponding audio would be broken
into sentences that shouldn't be less
than eight words long and shouldn't
be longer than 12 words long.
I'm just thinking outside the box
here, I don't know to what extent that
is practical or not, but there's a
real advantage in studying material
in what I call sentence mode, Uh, in
terms of, you know, maybe reviewing
the new characters that were in that
sentence, the ability to sort of
scramble the sentence and
put it back together again.
The, uh, matching pairs exercise
you can do with the three or four
words that were in that sentence
that you're still trying to learn.
So if it were possible to find
content that's of interest to
you, the total lesson shouldn't
exceed, let's say 15 minutes.
Because you lose your, I don't know,
you start to want to get, get away
from this text after about 30 minutes
because it takes so long and, and yet
divided into sentences with the matching
audio uh, that would be a wonderful
use of, uh, artificial intelligence.
Maybe I could say I'm looking for
certain, um, vocabulary so I could write
something in English with the vocabulary
that I want have it very accurately
translated into the target language.
Say, you know, Levantine Arabic, and then
I would have very pleasant audio, you
know, text to speech in Levantine Arabic.
Is that ever gonna be possible?
I don't know.
Or is it always gonna be preferable
to listen to an authentic, you know,
voice, this raises another issue.
When you look at the, uh, things that
people recommend for, you know, potential
use for, um, artificial intelligence,
they always have these language bots.
So you can talk to a robot and the robot
answers you, but how meaningful is that?
I've never done that.
There's no question that if you have
a, a genuine, spontaneous interaction
with someone in the language you're
learning that is very high resonance.
You're struggling, you're clinging to
every word, that's very high resonance.
If you have a lesson with a tutor,
it's, it's still a human being.
It's, it's, it's better.
It's a little more authentic, but
it's also a little artificial.
So not quite as good in my view, as that
random, genuine encounter with someone.
So what about a chat bot?
Now what about if I'm talking to
a machine that's answering me, I
don't know how much I'd like that.
Would I want that chat bot to correct me?
I don't even want my tutor to correct me.
I mean she doesn't, I, I,
it's not that I would react
negatively, but I'm not interested.
I'm having a conversation.
I'm enjoying our conversation.
I don't necessarily wanna be corrected.
So if you have a chat bot, a bot
correcting you, how useful is that?
Again, I don't know.
I'm just throwing stuff out there.
Potential uses of AI, already
it has changed the way we learn.
I use text to speech all the time.
I use Google Translate all the time.
I use these automatic transcription
services when I'm in YouTube
and I'm looking at a, a video
on whatever the subject might
be, Uh, something from Lebanon.
It's gonna suggest a whole bunch
of other, uh, related type videos.
So is all of that gonna get better?
So it's becomes easier and easier to
find content of interest and then move
from there to a related content of
interest, all of which helps you sort
of zoom in on a particular range of, of
vocabulary, all of which makes the job
of the teacher easier because the teacher
doesn't have to prepare the material.
You don't have to buy a $200
textbook, such as I saw when
I visited Stanford University.
Language textbooks selling for $200.
You can get access to
all of this material.
And, uh, and even in terms of, uh, the
grammar, I mean, again, AI can help
you identify this particular word.
What is, uh, you know, the
conjugation of that verb?
And, and, uh, so forth.
You might be able to ask for material
which focuses in on the subjunctive mood
or the instrumental case or anything
in different languages, and get a whole
bunch of examples of that particular
structure, that pattern in the language
for you to listen to and read again.
It seems to me the potential, the
opportunities there are endless in
terms of making not only input more
efficient, making it possible to spend
less time looking for content, more
time on content that is compelling.
It can be used, I guess, for
evaluation and correction, but
it's not how I would use it.
And it can help you zoom in on certain
grammatical aspects of the language
that, you know, you're having trouble
with so you end up controlling,
through the material you're using to
learn from, you know, what you do,
where you focus, uh, and so forth.
So I'd be interested
in people's reactions.
I, I'm not an expert on AI.
I've just done a bit of Googling.
I know what I've been using within
LingQ, and I know what works for
me and what I would like to see.
So, I mean even like if you're listening
to something and you give a voice command
and say, repeat that five seconds like
you're listening in the car, it didn't
quite get that repeat and then repeat.
You could set that to be a three second
or a five second repeat, and that
little audio would repeat, for example.
There's another thing.
So I look forward to your ideas.
Uh, those are just some of mine
on the subject of artificial
intelligence and language.
Thank you for listening and,
and of course it is related to
because I'm very much input-based.
It relates to the issue of learning
through listening and reading, but
greatly improving the efficiency of
that input based learning, making that
input more and more compelling with
the use of artificial intelligence.
Thank you.
Bye for now.